strategy number two is not a typo
it is sad as icing okay you did look it
up before if you're curious it's it's
what we call that port then so I think
that I pronounce it I don't really know
which is when you you take two words and
you shove them together and you make a
new word right like um what's an example
so I said again try dormice ginormous
wood bit you know gigantic enormous okay
so anyway what is it a combination or
it's a combination of I think it's weird
because both of these words always be
the same thing but anyway it's a
combination of satisfied and suffice it
sufficient okay so this is the word that
means what is sufficient me when
something is sufficient it's enough it's
like that I don't know okay so what is
what is satisficing it means that rather
than going through a set of solutions no
I look the very very best one right
it just means just find one that'll do
the job okay and it doesn't have to be
the best one fine if it's enough if it's
sufficient then we'll just go with that
okay so here's my example because we've
shoes before every morning I wake up and
except for like holidays and that kind
of thing I generally wake up before the
Sun is up okay so it's full-on dark and
I don't like to use I don't like to turn
on lights and all that kind of thing
because most of the lights in my house
are food recipe and if you if you know
fluorescent lights are more power
efficient over long periods of time but
if you just turn on and it's an off
again it's really bad doesn't know why
the ignition of a fluorescent light
takes up about fifteen minutes of power
just the ignition okay so if you turn it
on and off and then on and off you just
half an hour of power okay so that's our
evil ways so instead instead I just use
this can you see it okay because this is
when it's always totally dark this is
this is enough okay
it doesn't it's not as bright obviously
but it'll do okay now I wake up and I'm
looking for socks okay now I am I own
like I don't know maybe 15 pairs of
socks okay
and most of them kinda like
combinations of black and blue or gray
but always none of them are the same
okay but here's the thing it's the
morning I'm kind of in a hurry and to be
honest you can't even see my socks
anyway okay oh yeah you're all looking
down now what I do is I don't take the
optimizing approach which is to look
through every single sock and then I
pick the ones that I'm most identical
okay what I do is that I get them and
it's quite dark right so I'm like this
kind of look like this one okay and then
I just I just pick up and that's enough
okay so obviously it wouldn't be
sufficient if I pick up a black one or Y
one I'm like okay I have standards all
right side it I don't take those but if
it's like black and dark grey I'm just
like whatever okay it's enough for me
it'll do it's sufficient so I go in then
okay
so what's up what is a less a less
trivial example of that rather than just
socks let's think on what was our
previous topic we were doing
communication systems right so I want
you to think of a router okay well now
do you remember there were three kind of
things which we said reside at the
center of a star Network okay what was a
router over the other two there were
there were no it's not computers but
things that joined other computers
together do you mean what do switches
right routers switches and one more the
simplest one was a hum okay now do you
remember they sort of said that was in
reverse order routers are the most
complicated and switches and hubs more
simple what was special about a router
what kind of rather do which other
things fun okay all right so it's
sending a signal right and it chooses
where exactly what steps that sinner
should take to get to its destination
okay now how does it choose this is a
decision support system question how
does it choose which path to go up what
do you think it's um prioritizing what's
its goal speed generally okay now can
anyone tell me why generally speaking
order router
sorry if it's trying to get
that's the speed why wouldn't it
optimize why wouldn't it go this yeah
that's right right if you think about as
you will have the number of nodes
increasing right between a a source and
destination okay at the moment there's
just one way okay when you add in two
nodes okay well there's not there's not
two ways right you can go here and then
here or here and then yeah
or you can go here and then here I don't
know why you know say you see you didn't
want to use this connection here and you
do want to use connection so you go that
way so you have more combinations as I
put in war you can see the more
the more combinations there are it's
very good confusing okay and these are
all connected to each other at the
moment that's a mesh that's a full mesh
but it was a partial mesh it's a very
very complicated problem and then you
add in something slower than others and
some are longer than others and it's
just it's confusing
so if you were to optimize this would
take you forever by the time you made
the decision your signal could have
arrived right if you've just sent it
okay so what do most routers do okay
well they say look I just want to pick a
path that that'll do it that'll do the
job okay it'll be a reliable it'll get
there in sort of like a reasonable time
and so it just picks one because there's
all these different options right and
it'll take forever if it weighed them
all up it just picks one that will do
okay so even though that's communication
systems it's still a decision support
system kind of question a really
important idea that you want to get
along with satisfaction is what are the
minimum criteria what things must I
absolutely satisfied before I say yeah
I'm okay with this solution all right so
with my socks my minimum criteria is
vaguely the same shade not opposite
shades solos they're not black and white
I'm good okay
once I get anything that meets those
meeting criteria off I go put them on
him I forget about the first day okay so
once you meet the minimum criteria for
instance say you're driving the car
right can I get from A to B in less than
15 minutes I don't care if it's 12 or 13
or 14 as long as I can get there in 15
that'll do me okay so it doesn't matter
which one you
they're all sufficient all right it may
still involve some testing but certainly
not as much and not to his fine detail
level that make sense okay all right
does anyone else have any questions that
satisfy soon